how is it that you see the future of
this world and what is what is the kind
of responsibility you want to take for
this world my disability will be to talk
and never stop talking never stop and
never begin to feel fear or nothing can
change it will be worse and worse okay
the future okay like I don't know again
but what I'd like to all of us like all
all of us to achieve somehow is the
world in which like debates like this or
debates with other people are still
relevant and possible yes because there
comes like what history taught us is
that there are moments in history were
roundtables and were like public debates
were like simply no longer possible and
people know no longer read books or
articles so the idea like what the word
I would like it to be is that I'd like
the word to preserve preserve it's this
quality of being able to read discuss
appreciate what's happening around and
like find out that like the magic
mountain like the building magic
mountain is actually like in the people
around in a sense I don't think people
committed to a life of an of ideas are
an extinct or an extinct species are
becoming extinct I think that there are
a lot of people like this I don't think
that we're such miracles and what I want
is to be to live a life dedicated to
humanism and to those tis the ideals to
which Nexus is dedicated not in a
self-conscious way and not sort of
defensive because I think that we're a
dying breed but proudly and to represent
those values in a way that makes it
clear to anybody else who feels that way
that this is a this is a mission we can
take on
together I think you're in a snowstorm
right now and that's really it will come
back to the tower back I think I really
hope us to find the way out of the
sanatorium you know and not spend so
many years there and between the two
extreme positions as I think it was
decided this morning that there are so
many shades in between which are much
more interesting much closer to life and
I want us to look at these shades
between the extreme positions that we
heard this morning and to actually find
a way out of this I consider it a bit of
a paralyzes that we're in you said
before that when we're talking about the
climate crisis that the agenda needs to
be broadened but I just want to say that
I think for young people being faced
with the idea that humanity as we know
it might be coming to an end in their
lifetime and they won't have any food to
eat or air to breathe or any way to live
I think there's nothing more terrifying
than that so all of the other issues are
also very important but there's really
nothing more globally unifying than the
end of the planet in the end of the
world and and I think that we should all
be constantly using all of our skills
and resources and platforms to be as
involved as we can whether we want to or
not because we have to that's really all
that matters is really coming up with
solutions and and not just talking about
it but offering tangible solutions and
discussing them in pushing for them and
also taking care of each other and being
collaborating and being compassionate
and being loving and kind to each other
and working together so love will save
the world
and actions
I think God willed to be after the Arab
Spring an Arab summer I think I've
learned that there is no predicting
anything these days but I think what I
really appreciate is having this kind of
interdisciplinary space to talk to
people who are coming from very
different types of movements very
different types disciplines and I think
that doesn't happen enough so I think
you know I think the climate crisis and
the financial crisis I think have both
told us similar things which is that
people need to think about the economy
in different ways it's not just
economists it's actually how to think
collectively collective intelligence
about the impact of these institutions
for all of us and so there's too much
sort of you know doctors talking to
themselves economists will curtain sales
engineers or social activists you know
having this kind of interdisciplinary
space to actually talk about these
problems and challenges from different
perspectives is really useful and I
think also having a more holistic
approach to our well-being I think is
really important I think you know as you
were mentioning in the beginning you
know maybe 20 years ago the idea of
economic progress was the only thing and
this vision of humans is sort of
economic man was you know dominant and
now all of this you know climate change
activists and others are calling this
into question and I think we need to
have a more sort of holistic
understanding of our well being what we
need you know we need an economy that
also addresses the needs of society and
also doesn't destroy society in the
planet
you